everyone I'm Alana and welcome to my
channel and today I'm talking about all
the crazy things that I have in store at
e3 2018 and was gonna do this as part of
a predictions video like I did last year
but that would feel a little bit shady
this year I feel like I know a little
bit too much for that to be genuine and
the predictions videos that I have
already done on IGN have been me just
like pulling at things that I don't know
about to try and like find something so
it just comes across as random and
creative but I did want to tell you guys
very exciting news I am competing in the
Smash Bros Invitational the games to be
playable on Nintendo switch and I am
competing in Nintendo's official
tournament this is all part of a live
stream it's happening Tuesday June 12th
and it'll be directly after the splatoon
Wild Championships is when we go in to
the Invitational and playing alongside a
bunch of people who will way cooler than
me like Zelda Williams for example she's
named after a Nintendo character I know
I'm really excited about this I don't
know exactly what the plan is but I
believe that I will be playing from
around 2:30 you'll be able to watch the
stream on all of Nintendo's channels and
my current plan is to play cubby I'm a
cubby man anyway but I have been mostly
playing Mike in recent years but with my
logic is that we're going to have a
version of smash on switch that nobody's
played at this point I don't know which
characters are going to be playable
I think link is a safe bet I figured
cubby was also a safe bet and I'm Way
better at cubby than I am at link but
yeah I think you'll be able to get
tickets on the day of June 12th doors
open and I believe 10 all that info is
on III Nintendo comm if you want to find
out but I'm very excited I'm definitely
not going to win I just don't want to
lose that's all my plan is to keeping it
humble so that's just one thing I'm
doing aside from that I'm going to be on
the IGN livestream so much so I
basically just wanted to tell you guys
what the stuff is that I'm going to be
on
aside from stuff that is
currently embargoed sooo I'm on the EA
press conference at 10:30 a.m. we'll be
doing our pre-show predictions all that
kind of conversation talking about
anthem
yeah the originals which is a program
that I'm really interested in what we
might get from Star Wars all that good
stuff and then I'm actually going to
stay on the live show until 2 p.m. so
I'll be on from 10:30 a.m. to 2:00 p.m.
without a break
you watch that ign.com youtube.com slash
IGN and of course I tweet tons during
the press conferences then I've got more
interviews that afternoon and then I'm
going alive for the Xbox press
conference Sunday that's at 12:30 I'm
hosting that one I'm really excited
about it I've never been able to like
single-handedly host anything at e3 for
IGN big now let me do it by myself with
me being the one reading the prompter if
the literally is it been like guys I can
do this I have so much experience doing
this so this is my first year actually
doing that and like planning all the
stuff we'll be talking about and how
long we'll be talking about each thing
and I'm really excited I think I'm most
interested to see what Xbox has to bring
at e3 as well because this is the one
that I know the least about I know one
game that's definitely only B then
unannounced but aside from that I don't
know anything and I just feel like it's
a really important year for Microsoft
like they've been talking that big talk
about first party studios and about the
importance of exclusives and how they
realize they screwed up on that they
kind of got to bring it this year they
got to show us that they met that when
they said it so I'm very interested to
see what they show this year then I'm
also going to be on a live show for the
Bethesda press conference which starts
at 6 p.m. Pacific time again on our pre
shows IG Nicole you should go duck home
slash IGN I think it's on e3 duck
twitter.com and twitch.tv slash IGN as
well so all of the places come Monday
I'm live for the Ubisoft press
conference and I'm hosting that one as
well
very excited really really really want
to see beyond good evil - I just want to
know what multiplayer looks like in that
game like my biggest concern is that
Beyond Good and Evil 2 is going to be
more focused on a shared world
experience and less on the story but I
mean watchdogs 2 had pretty
balance it had a solid story and solid
multiplayer elements so I don't know I
think I'm just so attached to the first
game that I like like don't screw it up
and then I'm also live that night after
again more interviews with the
PlayStation press conference and the
pre-show for that one starts at 5:30
p.m. Tuesday of course is the Nintendo
Donovan I never hustles in the morning
one two things on the live show I'm
going to see a game then really [ __ ]
and then playing the game and then I
will be going to fortnight that night
and then Wednesday at those Andy's full
of games that I'm actually getting to
play which I'm really excited about I'll
give my impressions here of I'll give my
impressions here of as many of them as I
can and yeah I'll mostly be tweeting
impressions I'll probably share some
stuff my Instagram too but I don't know
you guys I really love you three I am
recording this video at 2 a.m. I
basically don't sleep at all during e3
week definitely don't been eating enough
lately I just haven't time to eat it's
it's crazy but every year I'm so so
excited and just love that I get to go
to e3 and I get to do this stuff I just
hope that something that's announced can
make me cry well Stuart was a young good
people too
this year I'm hoping that it's fatal I
really want Xbox to announce a new fable
that would be the thing that would
pretty much make this show for me of
course I always want to see new IP as
well I'm very curious about deaths
trainings release day at loss to spot
twos release day
what's going on with Halo 6 what's going
on with keys I wanted you Doublemint
cryo really bad where as an equal to
remake Final Fantasy 7 remake Kingdom
Hearts 3 released it was crackdown 3 is
delayed is it cancelled just a lot of
questions that I have that I really want
answers to so hopefully we get some of
those answers and yeah it would be
awesome if you guys want to shoot into
e3 conferences if you watched our
coverage I'm really excited and so much
work goes into e3 I think III is the
kind of week where it's like everyone in
IGN is going full-speed using like 100%
of that capacity to make stuff and just
working so hard and a lot of people to
everyone in the office is working
towards this one common goal for the
only time of the year really and so I
hope that we can share that hard work
with any of you
who are interested in watching III so
wish me luck
if I look dead by day - it's because I'm
already dead on the inside if you see me
around the shop floor feel free to say
hi the only thing that I do want to know
it to people is that sometimes I
literally have to run between
appointments like literally sprinting
between things
I'm not joking this isn't an
exaggeration we sometimes have to do
that so if I'm like yeah you can take a
photo or whatever just have to run with
me then that's that's what we got to do
and that is it for me today everyone I
have a lot of crazy stuff going on just
in June in general so I hope that you
stay tuned okay thank you guys watching
just an update for everyone who's
interested I'm Alana and I will see you
guys next time Oh